okay so this is a this is a chapel in
Prague in the Czech Republic that was
built a long time ago in the Baroque
period and that's what we're going to
find out let's go in the subject today
is chirality that comes from a Greek
word care which means hand and that's
where the word surgery comes from the
surgery is people that work on you with
their hands and instead of giving you
medicine but we're talking about
chirality which was the word that was
thought up about a hundred years ago by
a guy named Lord Kelvin and it has to do
with hands with handedness it has it's
involved things which are mirror images
of one another like your two hands but
are not superimposable they're not
identical they're obviously very very
similar to one another but they're not
the same thing and they occur all kinds
of places for example in art and
architecture you can see that this
column on the left has a spiral on it
and it's a right handed screw but the
one on the right side unfortunately it's
a left-handed screw but it's not only in
heart in our connection that you see
mirror and it just like this also in
biochemistry have you ever seen this
stuff does anybody know what it is yeah
what isn't DNA right and so here we have
one that's spiraling one way and over
there we have one that's spiraling the
other way and it happens in molecules to
which which organic chemists like me
work with like sugars carbohydrates are
right and left-handed amino acids and
proteins the stuff that made you are
right and left-handed the molecules of
life on Earth are what's called homo
chiral those are all the same hand so
for example you only have the right
handed screw of DNA and with not the
left-handed screw and you only have the
l-series amino acid you only have the
right hand and glucose in you now this
raises some questions the first one is
why why not have both well there's some
pretty easy explanations for why that
one is recognition let's see you ever
shake hands with people here let's shake
and shake hands with your neighbor but
one of you put out on the left hand that
feels really funny right my gran bills
differently so it makes a difference
which hand you use if you're interacting
with something else that's a certain pan
right and molecules in biology interact
with one another so they have to be the
proper hand to interact correctly so
that's recognition also efficiency if in
here in doing your biology you're only
and you don't want to waste a lot of
your food making the wrong stuff and
have to throw it away so it's much more
efficient to be able with just one hand
now sometimes you do have both hands
like these things that are called
essential oils they're called essential
not because you need them but because
they have an essence they have the smell
so cargo is a compound that comes into
both hands and there are little vials
going around that you can open up and
smell one of them and one of them is the
our cargo on one hand and that is
spearmint and the other one the left
handed cargo is caraway or dill seed or
rye bread so sometimes you use both but
almost always biology uses only one and
when it uses both it uses them for
different spit and for different
purposes like being right rather the
experiment also the shape of a polymer
it's really important ANSYS dealings of
DNA and every molecule is the same and
go around it even if suddenly you put in
the wrong hand it would go a different
way in another way and we've got all
messed up in your DNA wouldn't work at
all if it were a mixture of hands so
that's why biology deals with just one
hand
why biology is home Kyra now there's an
interesting question when when did life
become homicidal it's like the question
of the chicken and the egg which one
came first
is the question of life and hand we
can't imagine life without all things
being the same hands nowadays so but the
way we did single hands is from life
so which one came first the light or the
hand is not obvious and in either case
there's the question of how how was the
original selection made to get just one
hand and which I think any chemist you
talk to or biologists will say that if
all of us became our mirror image and
the whole biosphere all the trees of
bacteria and everything were their
mirror image everything would work just
fine but they're all one way what
decided which one we would be okay so
the title that got you here was did life
grind to a start and you can imagine
early life living on the beach of our
sand and waves of grind things off okay
now get us especially chemists of a
certain age get interested sometimes in
how life began and there for example the
story in the New York Times a few years
ago is that chemist shows how hard they
had read the starting point for life
this is a guy named John Sutherland
who teaches in and
at Cambridge in England now and so he's
studying how the molecules to begin but
not the part about which and that is I'm
not going to talk about the kind of
stuff people what I'm going to talk
about is a brief history of the origin
of Homo chirality how could things have
become one hand before life not that I
really know that they did become one
hand before life but that's the chicken
and the egg thing is there any way it
could have become one hand before there
was life controlling now of course
nobody knows that and nobody is really
likely to know that I don't think so
I really and for example Francis job in
1898 and we'll talk about him a little
later said the absolute origin of
compounds of one side an asymmetry to be
found in the living world is a mystery
as profound as the absolute origin of
life itself unfortunately for me it's
still a mystery right the origin of life
so on the chirality began I don't know
so I'm not even going to talk about that
what I'm going to talk as a brief
history of some ideas about the origin
of cocoa chirality and we're going to
start way back when and we're going to
go in steps of about 50 years to see the
ideas to plan so it all starts as you'll
see how it's related to the idea of
polarized light how many of you have
ever interacted with polarized light how
many of you ever wore sunglasses
you've interacted with polarized light
if their boots on glasses so let me show
you here this is there was what puck
thought this guy polish was interested
in was what if what is the nature of
light and a discovery he made was that
light can be polarized so I have here a
filter that's just one kind of light
through and here you can see that light
comes through and here it doesn't and
the idea here is the light which we now
know that he didn't know his vibration
of electrical field so electrons migrate
and then make an electric field that
goes back and forth but it goes all
different directions back and forth this
way one electrons going this way wants
to go on this way what's going this way
so all the direction but if you put then
that makes waves coming to you as the
lake comes to you up and down back and
forth back and forth but if you had a
big fence there only the waves that are
going the same direction is the slats
are enough to get through it not the
ones that are going this way and that's
what this does
so that should the light headed aspect
about it might lead so that's like a
picket fence one way and here's a picket
fence the other way and as we turn it we
if it's two sets of picket fence at the
same the light will come on through but
if one's perpendicular the other one it
will stop so we see that okay that's
what my this did it discovered polarized
light
so let's see what happens if we put a
piece of glass there and we take this
and it's just the glass is no different
from the front from that light that
doesn't move through the glass right
well let's put something in there like
let's take my water again that water
maybe the water out and instead I'm
going to put in care of serum after I
get those extra back let me get it
focused a little bit just so we don't
see the surrounding we'll just see that
light is coming from here I'm going to
put care of Sara in here which I got
yesterday in the stop and shop
and it's very sticky so so far so good
now watch this
it's a lot better than the room lights
off we're having trouble with three
planes and I'm not going to risk it okay
so that's karo Sierra is doing something
to the light the glass didn't do and
water didn't do and camera Sarah
turns out to have molecules that are
just one hand because it's like sugar
number sugar insanity okay so that
phenomenon was discovered just a few
years later but the rotation apply units
called by john baptiste bo and what
would this rotation well I was rotating
that thing so that seemed to have
something but I'm going to show you
another example and for this one we
really do need it to be pretty dark to
see
and now here you see that green laser
light and you see it going up through it
- that has sugar in it that is his
parents character and what does anybody
notice anything about this green line
can you see it against the dark can you
see what's funny about the green line
somebody dumping it comes in little bits
right there dark areas of the line how
can anybody see that that it's light
some places and then dark and then light
and then dark now I want people to tell
me where it's dark now so everybody's
not talking at the same time I'm going
to ask someone over on this side do I
have a volunteer over there yeah okay I
see is just just behind the aisle and do
I have volunteer on this side yeah okay
so I said yeah and I'm ready to hold can
you see that this little light and see
the green at the same time I want you to
call out when I hit the duck the center
of the dark area okay call out when I
hit the center of the dark area I'll
start at the bottom and start going up
and tell me one of those two people call
out and tell me
dark dark wait a second try again dark
dark now it is a company agreed was the
guy over on the hunt my right over here
how many people agree with those you
guys say I agree how many agree with a
guy on the left it's a stereo people on
this side agree with the guy on the
right and to the left
what's going on well what's going on
isn't this light the polarization of
this light as it goes through the sugar
is rotating now we can get a little
light back on the subject if somebody
did somebody else
and it's like this the direction that
people remember the light was it was
feel pushing electrons back and forth
now sometimes it's it's like it's
twisted as it goes up this - sometimes
it's pushing this way sometimes this way
so over here tell me what you can't see
the ribbon and what I write there over
here one can you see the ribbon there
it's different places because it's
twisting and you're looking at it from
different angles so that's the rotation
of polarized light the electric field
they did the vibrating electric field is
rotating those through sugar but doesn't
rotate as it goes through water and the
reason is the different colors of light
rotate different amounts it's not the
fraction it's with this rotation
so so the reddit rotates or the degrees
so sometimes you see the red subnet you
see the green or blue okay now we're
gonna go now to talk about polarized
light we're going to go 40 years later
to 1848 and to this guy who was a young
guy now these previous guys is 40 years
later so they're they're as old as I am
today
in fact this guy's supervisor was one
year older than I am at this time and
this guy was only as you can see 26
years old much closer to you okay
so he was trying to learn to be a
scientist that he was trying different
kinds of science he was trying Tristan
Lockerbie in chemistry and physics and
1848 he made some observations and wrote
a paper and the title of the paper was
the relations that can exist among
crystalline form so that's
crystallography chemical composition
that's chemistry and the direction of
wrote the rotatory polarization that's
this phenomena we thought about he did
run neither to the right nor to rotate
from the left it goes up so he was
trying to tie these different
disciplines together so this is a
picture of crystals
he starts with this so look at figure
six down here and suppose that that
sharp edge you sand it off to make a new
base on the crystal like one that looks
like that so then you get others and you
see the one to the right of that has
such faces so let's look at this one
which is a crystal of what's of assault
and tartaric acid tartar was stuff that
came inside wine casks so they were to
personalize it they were dealing with
that was personally out of that stuff
and there you see the blue one of these
spaces but notice the symmetry in
principle there's not just one base like
that
there should be four of them like that
right because the prism is the chrismas
to be symmetric so there should be four
such cases and there are four such bases
but suppose you cut off that little edge
to make a new tiny base up there right
now how many of those did you have you
should have Forum on that end of the
crystal and forum on this end of the
crystal so there should be eight of
these on in the salt tartaric acid or
his pasta I wrote in 1848 two hundred
fifty years ago
talk about 150 years ago meeting the 82f
edges should be modified the same way so
he looked at in carefully and he saw
that's not true it was always the same
for only four of them appeared on the
crisp up those little classes not all
eight but this didn't surprise it you
notice that they form a sort of a twist
right from one from the faces on the
left end to the
greater than twists like that substance
tartaric acid when you put it in water
and rotate slightly same phenomena so
there was a rotation in the in the
crystallography and there was a rotation
in the physics once you put it into
water now there was another salt you can
get from wine and it was all recipe and
it had the same chemical formula as as
the target rate did but the previous
Authority had reported that crystals of
this compound which don't do this trick
of rotation when you put it in white
that they had the same shape as the
country and posture thought that just
can't be right
if surely not should crystals from this
untwisted version if the molecules
aren't twisted then the crystal
shouldn't be twisted even let me just
put this down
so this is so he so he went to look
carefully at this one thinking that now
you should see always because the
molecules aren't twisted they aren't
doing this trick ok and what he saw was
really interesting then some of them
looked exactly the same as card trading
but others had the other set other four
out of those eighty so some crystals
look like some crystals look like this
and other crystals look like that so
what the heck did he figure was going on
so he separated the two that were
twisted in one way and twisted the other
way and dissolved them in water to see
what happened and this is what he said I
carefully separated the right from the
left prisms and observing their
dissolution separately with Monsieur Bo
is polarization apparatus I saw with
surprise and delight that the right
crystals turned the polarization to the
right and the left crystals to the point
so now he knew what was going on then
rasa made was a mixture half of them was
this other stuff partly that he'd
already studied and the other half is
the peer in each other and so there were
two kinds of molecules and they were
together that is they were together in
the sample system of one person would be
wanted one
so this was the first time that a
chemist separated molecules that were
mirror images from one another
this is chemistry's first permissible
separation of mirror image molecules and
you know his his teacher Bo who was old
like me right didn't believe this could
be true so he had young pasta or common
he supplied it for acetic acid and he
said use my racemic acid use my machine
to measure this rotation and do it in
front of me and it worked so that was
the first time that that had happened so
it showed that the molecules somehow
twisted was that he wasn't the only one
that could do this microbes can do it
too because he took a mixture of the
right-handed and left-handed tartaric
acid and as he took that receiving acid
and he put yeast with it and what
happened was that the yeast grew but it
left the left-handed acid it only ate
one of them so it left the other so the
yeast could separate them to eat up one
and leave the other one and this is very
important nowadays because many drugs
that are used in medicine are handed and
until us until about 20 years ago they
were always sold as a mixture of right
and left and those things will behave
differently just like shaking hands is
different right and left-handed and it
turned out the one of them could be good
for you and the other one a poison right
so they had now such compounds are all
made in one form so that they'll work
properly
and this is what this observation is
what that posture to be a microbiologist
to determine to do pasteurization for
milk and so on was the study of microbes
that he got into because he was studying
chemistry and physics and
crystallography but it raised the
question then once you knew the
molecules were handed what determined
the chirality of life whether it was
right or left-handed that posture said
it was the first principles of lighting
front is symmetric that is handed there
according to B is one of the ties
between life on the Earth's surface and
the cosmos that is to say the set of
forces spread throughout the universe
that is there must be some force in the
universe that determines it to be one
hand and not the other hand now there is
such a force it's called the weak force
but it's not called the weak force or
nothing it's really really really weak
and I don't think they're very few
chemists who believe it could do this
trick right so there probably is
something else that handles now that's
nothing it's not only in solution that
things can rotate light you can have
crystals that rotate like Michaels this
bottle here is sodium chlorine assault
it has nothing to do with life and these
are crystals grown from that
but if you put them between cross
Polar's right so the light gets through
the background is black but some light
is coming through the crystals they're
rotating it but if you look if you hug
if you rotate those boulders like I was
doing here you can see that there are
two kinds of crystals there two of the
crystals are right-handed if you are
left-handed so you can get that happen
that way and that is called optically
active when it's able to do this trick
of rotating light but this stuff that
salt is not chiral when it's in solution
the molecules are not chiral but the
crystal is chiral but that's not really
too surprising that sodium chlorine and
solution is not chiral
because chiral structures could be built
from a Tyrolean secret eight bricks
which are not right left-handed and they
go right to editor a left handed helix
you can do the same thing with Legos
that are not trying to come in okay now
if we're going to go over 50 years into
the future into 1898
so a little more than a hundred years
ago and I'm going to ask you a question
which hand if you crystallized this
stuff sodium chlorine which hand would
you expect to get in your interview now
I know that some of you are pretty young
and has trouble thinking about things
like this and some of you are pretty old
and have trouble thinking about
but let's just guess do you think you're
more likely to get right or left or
50/50 how many people think right how
many people think left how many people
think you're most likely to get a 50/50
that's my father democracy wins it
should be good okay 50/50 I guess this
was what hypnotoad thought little over
100 years ago so they wanted the test
there's hope when he was later he was a
professor at Cambridge but this time he
was just a student and here are the
results
so he did many he did 46 different
beakers and groom missiles and then he
counted them how many World right hands
and how many to the left hand and he
wrote down in this column
how many right-handed there were in this
column how he left him where he did it
for 46 different experiments so in those
the total in those 46 crystallisation x'
is what you expected out of 3128
crystals there were fifteen hundred
sixty-two right-handed and 1566
left-handed almost exactly 50/50 in fact
if you look at it there there's where it
is on the scale it's right at the hidden
e and it's it's if you do statistics on
this you say it's plus or minus one
percent right so it's 50/50 which is
what you said so you were right but now
let's look at individual runs then this
confirmed their hypothesis they thought
it would be they said they wrote the
average product that the large numbers
civilizations of Soviet chlorine from
water should insist the 50% of crystals
in each and a foul
now let's look here here in the third
run they had 64 right and 69 left so
that's pretty good again it's 50/50
within the error and then let's look at
this one there's 24 - 68 that's not
50/50 with respect to the error and
here's one that's that's in the other
direction here's another one this way so
individual ones are not 50/50 but all
over there which is what they wanted to
find it what they found
now there's an interesting lesson in
this thing
notice that this back feed not far off
statistics what happened one time in a
hundred twenty five when you do it it
should be that far away and they did 46
so maybe they were just unlucky you'd
expect that at 125 times you'd expect to
get it maybe you've got it within 46 but
this would happen one day one time in
nine hundred and that would happen all
in one - fifteen thousand and this one
would happen only one time and a quarter
million at random would it be that far
away so this is not random right
obviously there's some correlation
within some of the runs where you have
one hand you tending in that hat but
still overall they got very near
fifty-fifty
this is it only one time in 18 would you
expect to get that
now maybe they were just lucky maybe
they walked out but they were the one
time in AD when you would get that
closer than 50/50 but maybe not let's
look let's this is what they wrote the
experiments are numbered in the order in
which they were performed and order
further to eliminate personal bias no
calculations whatever were made until we
considered that a sufficient number of
experiments have been completed to
ensure an accurate average in fact as
little attention as possible was paid to
the laboratory lists at Baylor until the
observations were concluded now this
raises a question just how little
attention can you pay to these numbers
is your main that you're measuring them
they said they did a sufficient number
of experiments well they did 46
personalizations right
but why 46 and why 3128 crystals why not
do 50 experiments or why not three
thousand crystals and then stop well
since they bit up in this order we can
see what would have happened if they had
stopped after the first of the second or
the third of the fourth of the fifth we
could see where they were going
so let's look at that so here the first
one so they're very near fifty-fifty
that's zero on this thing so they're
very near fifty-fifty okay that looks
good and then suddenly this thing that
would only happen warm time and a
quarter million occurred right took this
way off so they kept going
you got even worse the Dennis started
getting better and then it got worse and
then it's starting to get better and
better now it's getting really good oh
goes away but then it comes back and
there it's 1532 fifteen thirty they did
one more and it started going away and
they quit now they were very they were
very honest people I'm sure but it's
very hard when you're doing experiments
not to not to put a bias in favor of
what do you expect to see very hard to
avoid subconscious bias
now that's a near indeed 98 the subject
came up at the annual meeting of the
British Association for the Advancement
of Science in Bristol and England and
was the take place in Colston Hall which
is shown here but there was a problem it
was the start on September night but
actually on September first pulsed the
hall burned to the ground and the venue
for their placement looked like this on
September 9th when they were supposed to
begin so they had to go someplace else
so the president's so Sir William
Crookes was the president and he was
forced to deliver his presidential
inaugural address not in beautiful coast
at all but in a music hall of people's
palace and this is what he said I
elected to speak on the still debatable
subject which does not yet enlist the
interest of the majority and my
scientific
confirmation of telepathic phenomenon is
afforded by many converging experiments
now some of you young people don't know
what
telepathy is it's like if I do think you
can hear might even understand my
thinking without me saying anything or
showing you anything even if you're
halfway around the world and there are
not many scientists now and there not
many scientists there that believed
there was anything then believed there
was anything to do that but that's what
the president has done a scientific
associations lectures about and there
was a report on this in the famous
science magazine nature
Sir John Evans prophesied when
introducing Sir William to the chair
that the Association would hear from him
a remarkable address and that prophecy
has been amply justified and they got
what they expected together from Sir
William whose name incidentally is right
on the front of this building but this
was not the meetings most controversial
topic and most controversial was in
chemistry and was a lecture by Francis
Jack who was the president of the
chemistry section and his title was
stereochemistry that is chirality this
handedness and vitalism that is that
special stuff that happens with life and
he's delivered this talk at the Young
Men's Christian Association
he said the contention of these got
these chemists of others that now that
we discovered enzymes we can understand
everything in biology just in terms of
chemistry we don't need for special
magic involving biology it's all the
chemistry now Bobby says this leaves
intact the vitalistic origin of these
phenomena how did you get this one hand
and that they're not answering
no fortuitous Concours abuses very fancy
language here no fortuitous pot course
of atoms even with all eternity for the
equation combined him couldn't compass'
the speed of the formation of the first
optically active compound coincidence is
excluded and every purely mechanical
explanation of the phenomenon must
necessarily fail there must be something
special not like chemistry and biology
you can't just I see no escape from the
conclusion then that the woman went like
first arose a directed force into the
plane a force of precisely the same
character as that kitchen tables the
intelligent operator by the exercise of
his will to select one crystallized need
and ignore and rejected it's asymmetric
opposite that is he thought there was
some spirit in the universe that could
choose the one certainly an argue the
insufficiency of mechanical explanation
is metaphysical I must plead
and as he knew that scientists with
lightness when he finds support for it
in Newton's Principia and let's not go
into the light here but essentially what
Newton wrote was that there must be a
being existing in order to make this
happen and he did he says he will merely
add that that must be soap in the 19th
century was not sympathetic than this
kind of viewpoint so within the next
three months sixteen people wrote
letters are doing about this in the
magazine nature and then the Herbert
Spencer who thought of the idea survival
of the fittest says it seems to me that
right and left with the same game but
that's kind of question of right left in
each other it's a question of choosing
just one not the other so you don't have
the other one so he didn't understand
what's the problem was Carl Peterson who
was a discoverer of many things in
statistics and also a rather sketchy
idea called eugenics that we don't need
to go into said I think that that a
slight chance for quadrants as the
breeding going so chance that statistics
and breeding is what's involved in
Jennings so he was just trying to use
words and he said it if you put these
mirror image things in a barrel up
rotated it he wouldn't be surprised to
see that they went to opposite ends
that's amazing but in fact it's been and
the physicists in Ireland GM is Gerald
it was moment relativity circles because
of thinking of Lorentz contraction
before harassin what was known locally
in Dublin for being the first first
person to try to
there he said it started must've started
with just one and that one must have
been either a right that or a left hand
and if everything else came from that
one then you could just get one hand
aureus ended so it was controlled by the
accidental symmetries and of the first
original crystal or he said the rotation
of the Sun and the heavens made it be a
sufficient cause because the Sun goes in
this way and not that way that may be
what mister
so there were lots of I needed but very
little basis for deciding which was
which should be which now we're going to
go fifty years further ahead
actually I'm footnote about how crystals
grow you may have noticed my PI as a lot
of Christians are so this guy in Germany
said tiny pieces of stone dissolve more
easily than large ones and then if you
have a mixture of the two sides of
different tiny ones will dissolve the
big ones will grow and you'll get all
the and the reason for this is that if
you have two crystals of different size
with lots of little pieces of the ones
on the inside of the happiness the most
stable so the larger one has a higher
fraction inside than the smaller one
does so it's more stable the average
molecule is more painful on a big one so
he put it in solution so that molecules
can come and go through the solution
they'll come off the lower and go on to
the big one so the idea is
that large business grow small
businesses all and therefore getting
that first crystal is a problem because
it's going to start small but small ones
aren't stable it's you ever heard of a
joke you can't get there from here and
that's about trying to hit crystals you
have that falls before big ones of the
small ones are the stable so how do you
do it so it's a hard thing to start
growing crystals so now we know we're
worried about how do you do hands and we
know that dissolve so this guy in in
Holland in in 1939 did an experiment
with that compound the chance of mirror
image and they're in solution and they
go back and forth okay but if you wait a
while you'll start crystallize it with
just one crystal and it will start to
grow but it has to be just one hand one
or the other and it drains everything
over into that and it all becomes one
hand so that's like what these guys are
saying but he showed that it can
actually happen and I'll show you one
other if you stir when you crystallize
you can do a bunch of things this is
something this is a little stirring bar
about that big in the solution there's
nothing an hour later
you'll be able to see
this corner crystal begins to appear
just one crystal and as time goes by it
flows out closer and closer to the stern
and finally you'll see in the stirrer
get the crystal and this is what it
visited jump jump so for 15 seconds it's
hitting the personal but notice any big
pieces and see how it's getting sort of
Grady the whole solution is getting
started reading and if you look down at
this corner you'll see little flashes of
light and what madness is light
reflecting off new crystals so for an
hour and a quarter there were only one
crystal what's that stir it's the
crystal suddenly there are a thousand
crystals in there and they're all safe
hands the first crystal so that not
because of the problem of getting small
crystals to get new business to grow if
you could not tiny pieces even once you
can't see off pre-existing crystal then
all the new crystals will come from that
so in fact even though there are
thousands of crystals in there they are
all really one crystal so they're all
the same hand now this this bottle which
is a kilogram does anybody know how many
pounds of kilogram is how many
two pounds to thousands of tiny crystals
is there okay and I bought that for a
doctor a bunch of money and I looked at
and here here's the here's the teeth of
more words and what you see is the
crystals from that bottle of 77 initial
crystals only two were left handed so it
was a hold one hand so I got a real
bargain when I bought this if they could
have charged a lot more money to have
them all be the same payout this 92 94
plus or minus 2% excess of one hand and
no extra costs I was lucky but see what
must have happened is when they made
this stuff they stirred it and one
crystal started and they knocked all the
others off that so this is surely a case
of secondary nucleation right so again
having just one original crystal gives
just one hand that's fine but this is
never going to work if you start with a
whole bunch of crystals because then you
have nuclei of all the hands and you can
never wait you can never be able to get
one
now we'll go 50 years of Rangers before
and we come to this paper converting a
polycrystalline mixture of sodium
authority to a single hand by grinding
now this isn't like the stirring for you
to start with one crystal you're
starting with a mixture of lots of
crystals so how can you possibly be that
I thought there's no way that this works
I didn't know the guy who did it was in
Spain and I thought it must be a crummy
scientist and it's just
right so I ignored it there's an
irritation to be some of the other
places maybe but he's not even in
companies and geologists and what he was
interested in was whether the weak force
would make it all be one hand and no
chemist believes that that could
possibly work but he's an amazing
scientist and he'll try things so he
tried it he's a wizard
so he took ten flasks and little stir
bars in about 50/50 of right and left
and started the wall stirring from
little water in so they could stir them
up right and then he got impatient so
after ten days he went to look now I
mean if any chemist thought it would
work they would never no chemist Allah
think it would work but if some of they
would think it would take about 50
million years to happen as the weak
force is so weak so but he got impatient
after ten days and he looked and to the
surprise of no one they were 50/50 still
except for flask 8/8 was 100%
left-handed and what he said was if an
experiment works something has gone
wrong so try again so he tried to get it
at the same thing again and again last
eight was 100 percent left hand now at
this point I would think that there's
something biological in flask 8 that's
somehow doing this although I wouldn't
know
but he thought it might be what room
they were in
so he changed the room between flats to
and flask 8 of tried again and again
class 2 was 50/50 the class games 100%
and then he noticed something that I
wouldn't have noticed this is like
posture found that both of those little
faces on the crystals this evening to a
rank left hand he looked at the stir
that was hidden playas came and saw was
different than a little riddle he
thought it must be that it's wobbling as
it stirs and grinding up the crystals
and that grinding is one good and here's
where he was in luck because he had
lived on the comude and he wore a bead
necklace and he thought if I think the
beads off my necklace have put him in
there and stir it it's going to grind
much better than it did without the weed
so that's precisely what he did he took
the beads off his necklace and put them
in there and here's a picture of the
class with the beads from his necklaces
and sure enough and one day it became
all
I didn't believe it I dismissed this as
an obviously inconsistent with
statistical mechanics and it worked here
at Yale 100 years ago said and a mixture
is going to be more stable than having
just one just can't happen that's what I
thought but then some Dutch people
together with some English people in
four different labs did the same kind of
experiment copied and they found that
they started with just a little more 10%
more of one right that left it became
when they started to grind it with glass
beads after a week it became a hundred
percent or if they started with a little
less and took a little longer but ball
went 200 percent they've started with
mostly left-handed it went to 100
percent and it was so it amplified
whatever was in even a little tiny
excess would become a hundred percent if
you were out when they found right and
it got faster it's faster and faster the
longer you go now I've got an email from
the editor of nature who said do you
find these observations convincing
obviously I didn't originally but these
people I knew the ones in power so I
thought you know it's convincing and he
asked if I would write a little article
about it at night and fortunately I
thought that because within a couple
years all these other molecules business
including down here on the right this
one which is a drug that sold for six
billion dollars a year of that has sold
as a single hand and normally people
paying a 50/50 mixture and throw half of
it away but here you can convert
everything by grinding in
one so it's worth you know half of six
six billion dollars a year maybe all of
six billion dollars here so editor asked
if I thought the bank was with the
reporting who is abused and I said yes I
do but I have no idea how it works so
how can I write something so it turned
out there was a fellow in Japan who had
published a complicated numerical
situation simulation of this now you
know some laughs but let me tell you
this kind of thing it's really really
complicated the only way to do with it's
a computer and even if you do it on a
computer and it works you don't know why
it work right so he got it something to
work but he didn't know why so that was
the question why so I talked to a person
who works in this building it's very
good a theory and we tried to figure out
why does that work so we have a
visualization of why it works so suppose
you have more of one than the other
right and and they just they put them in
water and they start to dissolve and you
get molecules in the solution but they
go both ways molecules go back onto the
principle as well as all right and if
you look at the red crystal just like
one broken crystals right so there's no
selection nothing that makes it better
for agreement for a red they look just
the same
so the ratio should have change that's
supposed to grind and knock off tiny
pieces remember tiny pieces will
dissolve right so that's not the mating
dissolution
so more stuff will go into solution
right but then again more stuff will
come from solution back one of the big
crystals right so again if you look at a
red and a green when they look the same
and there's no bias that favors green
over red the ratio should stay the same
now suppose we can have Christmas grow
by a completely different way that
people haven't been thinking about
suppose crystals to grow not only by
molecules going onto the crystal one of
the time but by two crystals coming
together and now if that happens you're
going to slow down these tiny but we're
going to dissolve so they'll all
dissolve except some will dissolve but
they can come back to join them the big
ones right then they'll be big but again
the right of the left look the same
except for one factor which is this
there are two ways to save this green
pistol if you go under this one
this one and there's only one way and
save the red crystal so the little green
ones are not as likely to dissolve as
the little red ones are because there
are more ways to save so the faster
dissolution of this goes through
solution right now this also could work
as long as you have this select crystals
growing this way to select this fashion
I'm going to skip it it also happens but
I'm going to go through this quickly
because time's going if the molecules
are chiral here so if you have this
selective attachment then this will work
so it can we get any evidence that you
do get crystals growing by two persons
coming together and here is if we take
left-handed crystals of that stuff so
the employee and right-handed crystals
that are dyed and we mix them all
together and put them in solution that
shape them in water and half the back
row notice what's happened here if I do
that stuff with a polarized light
they've gone together with their own
except
so it works and therefore this must work
it must be that whatever even is just a
tiny tiny excess if you grind it they'll
all come the same and it's not just
right it turns out that if you haven't
even take a boiling solution to here's
the same guy in Madrid does crazy crazy
things I took a bottle put a little
water and some of these crystals in put
them on the hot plate so it was 120
degrees Celsius back here 106 of the top
and after a while it started to snow
because of the solution and it made a
lot of tiny crystals and as they came
down the ones that there were more of
not saved by coming together so you
don't have to grind you can just boil it
okay so what process is the key is a
grinding no you to do it without
grinding shakey you can do it without
shaping boil and reflux
bubble formation temperature the key
thing is that you can give these
Christmas growing by coming together to
save the tiny person okay so the end of
ripening this process is a possible
source of the Earth's although chirality
great stuff up it Sam
or it couldn't so I accept the title
this was good life right into a story
but it could be that it boiled to a
start the things started in Iceland and
a geyser or something like that where
things were constantly boiling you could
enrich the one so remember at the
beginning we said that Frances chap said
every purely mechanical explanation one
of those letters in nature in search of
a venison invited the probable
spontaneous generation employment is not
likely ever to be reduced to the far
simpler question of the origin symmetry
is absolutely right there's an easy way
of doing it which is this writing but no
one had thought of it for 200 years and
find that this fellow in this doll
appear at least of all the end of
working with his helpers here and Madrid
I figured it out and I'll show you a
machine he admitted in fact how show did
not want in this machine he admitted to
shaking a sample
I'll show you receive himself and he
made for me
now that thing did not cost $200,000 you
know what it is what what is squared
this machine come from on the bottom is
a break for [ __ ] and what's this that
part here that's doing the shaking never
see such a thing
it's a sander he bought it for $8.00 so
there's still lots of simple things you
can do that no one has ever thought of
so it's wide open